there's a concept that I don't want to
be an icon I want to be an idea i want
to represent an idea i want to represent
possibilities I want to represent magic
that you're in a universe in two plus
two equals four
two plus two only equals four if you
accept that two plus two equals four two
plus two is gonna be what I want it to
be and there's a redemptive power that
making a choice has you know rather than
feeling like you're at a fete to all the
things that are happening make a choice
like you just decide what its gonna be
who you're gonna be how you're going to
do it just decide and from that point
the universe is gonna get out your way
it's light its water it wants to it
wants to move and go around stuff so for
me I want to represent possibilities I
want to represent the idea that you
really can make what you want one of my
favorite books is the Alchemist Paulo
Coelho I just believe that I believe
that I can create whatever I want to
create if I can put them put my head on
it right study it learn the patterns and
it's hard to put into words some real
metaphysical esoteric nonsense but I
feel strongly that we are who we choose
to be difference between depression and
joy I think its purpose it's like when
you wake up in the morning and your life
means something to somebody other than
you that you have a purpose if you don't
go do the things that you're going to do
people's lives will suffer and I think
that that kind of purpose to live in
service not to you but to live in
service to humanity to live in service
to your family to live in service to
your church to your city to your country
to the world living in service I feel
that is the purest form of joy you just
watched two amazing clips from Will
Smith take the next three minutes to sit
quietly and think about how you can
apply them to your business and your
life belief
[Music]
[Music]
you
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]